THE SITUATION ROOM.
>>> OUR TOP STORY TONIGHT, THE
TRUMP LEGAL TEAM ALREADY AT ODDS
WITH THE SPECIAL MASTER IT
REQUESTED, REFUSING TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS SEIZED
FROM HIS FLORIDA HOME.
CNN'S JUSTICE CORRESPONDENT
JESSICA SCHNEIDER HAS THE LATEST
ON THE MAR-A-LAGO INVESTIGATION.
>> Reporter: TONIGHT THE SPECIAL
MASTER BRINGING TOGETHER TRUMP'S
LAWYERS AND ATTORNEYS FOR THE
JULS S DEPARTMENT TO HAMMER OUT
HOW TO PROCEED WITH THE REVIEW
OF THE 1 # 1,000 DOCUMENTS TAKEN
FROM MAR-A-LAGO INCLUDING 100
DOCUMENTS MARKED CLASSIFIED.
TRUMP HAS REPEATEDLY ARGUED HE
HAS THE POWER TO DECLASSIFY
DOCUMENTS AND THAT HE DID
DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS AT
ISSUE.
BUT HIS LEGAL TEAM HAS YET TO
MAKE THAT CLAIM TO A COURT OR
PROVIDE EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP DID
SO.
IN A NEW FILING AT THE 11th
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
RESPONDING TO DOJ'S APPEAL
TRUMP'S TEAM HAS SAID IT'S ON
THE GOVERNMENT TO PROVE THEIR
CLASSIFIED.
THE GOVERNMENT PRESUPPOSES THAT
THE DOCUMENTS IT CLAIMS ARE
CLASSIFIED ARE IN FACT
CLASSIFIED.
HOWEVER, THE GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
YET PROVEN THIS CRITICAL FACT.
BUT TONIGHT JUDGE RAYMOND DEARY
WHO THE TRUMP TEAM HAD A DIRECT
HAND CHOOSING, SAID HE HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO CEPT THE
GOVERNMENT'S CLAIMS THAT THE
DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED.
IF TRUMP GIVES THE CONCRETE
PROOF.
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM ARGUING IT'S
TOO EARLY IN THE CASE TO REVEAL
ANY EVIDENCE OF DECLASSIFICATION
SINCE THAT COULD BE THE DEFENSE
IF TRUMP IS INDICTED.
BUT THE SPECIAL MASTER TELLING
TRUMP'S TEAM YOU CAN'T HAVE YOUR
CAKE AND EAT IT.
TRUMP'S ALLIES CONTINUE TO
CRITICIZE THE SEARCH OF
MAR-A-LAGO LAST MONTH, NOW 11
REPUBLICAN LED STATES HAVE FILED
IN SUPPORT OF TRUMP'S BID FOR
THE SPECIAL MASTER REVIEW.
IN LIGHT OF THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF
A PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION
RANSACKING THE HOME OF ITS
ONE-TIME AND POSSIBLY FUTURE
POLITICAL RIVAL.
>> NO ONE GETS TO KEEP
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION OUTSIDE
OF THE PLACE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION SHOULD BE.
BUT FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO BEHAVE THEY WAY THEY
DID BY RAIDING THE HOME OF A
FORMER PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> BUT REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
LIZ CHENEY WHO SERVES AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE PUSHING BACK AGAINST
THE IDEA THE DOJ ACTED
POLITICALLY.
>> ELECTED LEADERS OF MY PARTY
ARE NOW WILLING TO CONDEMN FBI
AGENTS, DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OFFICIALS AND PRETEND THAT
TAKING TOP SECRET FBI DOCUMENTS
AND KEEPING THEM IN A DESK
DRAWER IN AN OFFICE IN
MAR-A-LAGO OR IN AN UNSECURED
LOCATION ANYWHERE WAS SOMEHOW
NOT A PROBLEM.
BIT BY BIT, EXCUSE BY EXCUSE,
WE'RE PUTTING DONALD TRUMP ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> Reporter: AND THE NEXT MOVE
IN THIS COURT FIGHT COULD BE
FROM THE 11th CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS.
THEY COULD BE INCLINED TO MOVE
RATHER QUICKLY HERE SINCE THE
SPECIAL MASTER IS READY TO
REVIEW THOSE 100 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT DOJ WANTS TO KEEP
AWAY FROM HIM AND AWAY FROM
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM.
AS YOU KNOW IN COURT TODAY THE
DOJ ATTORNEY SAID QUITE SIMPLY
TO THE SPECIAL MASTER IF THEY
LOSE IN THEIR APPEAL OF THE 11th
CIRCUIT THEY'RE READY TO APPEAL
THIS FURTHER WHICH MEANS THIS
CASE COULD GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> THAT COULD TAKE A WHILE, TOO.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER REPORTING FOR
US.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL THAT'S GOING
ON.
OUR CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE ANALYST JOHN
MILLER.
THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM THEY WANTED
THIS SPECIAL AS HE'S CALLED, BUT
NOW JUDGE DEARY, JUDGE DEARIE
WANTS ANSWERS.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU FROM THIS
FIRST HEARING TODAY?
>> A NUMBER OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, DOES NOT ABIDE
NONSENSE, DOES NOT ABIDE LOGIC
AND ALL SORTS OF CLAIMS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE ON THE AIR WAVES,
ON TELEVISION PROGRAMS AND
RALLIES THE JUDGE IS NOT
SATISFIED UNLESS HE HEARS
EXPLANATIONS BROUGHT IN COURT.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, ON THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER THESE DOCUMENTS ARE
CLASSIFIED HE ESSENTIALLY SAID
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS MADE
WHAT LAWYERS CALL A PRIMA FACIE
CASE.
I THINK HE MADE VERY CLEAR HE'S
NOT GOING TO ACCEPT CIRCULAR OR
SILLY REASONENING OR ARGUMENTS.
HE'S GOING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THINGS.
HE'S GOING TO DO IT QUICKLY ON A
MORE FAST SCHEDULE THAN TRUMP
LAWYERS WANT, SO I THINK MAYBE
WHEN THEY PUT RAY DEARIE ON THE
LIST TO BE SPECIAL MASTER THEY
MAY HAVE GOTTEN MORE THAN THEY
BARGAINED FOR.
>> GOOD POINT.
THE JUDGE ALSO SAYS HE HAS TO
ASSUME THESE DOCUMENTS AREN'T
CLASSIFIED UNLESS THE TRUMP TEAM
ARGUES OTHERWISE.
SO WHY IS THE TRUMP TEAM
CONTINUING TO DODGE THIS
QUESTION?
>> WELL, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO PICK A LANE REALLY SOON, THUS
FAR DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PULL OFF THIS
DELICATE DANCE.
LUCKILY FOR ME CLASSIFIED.
THEY'RE SAYING WE RESERVE OUR
RIGHT, WE MAY ARGUE THIS LATER.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME.
BUT IT IS NOW CLEAR, WOLF,
DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
PROBABLY SOONER THAN THEY
EXPECTED IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CHOOSE.
ARE WE GOING TO SUPPORT IN GOOD
FAITH OR GIVE THAT ARGUMENT UP?
I THINK THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
GOING TO FORCE THAT DECISION ON
THEM PRETTY SOON.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
JOHN, IF TRUMP DID IN FACT
DECLASSIFY THESE DOCUMENTS AS
HE'S CLAIMED, THERE WOULD BE
EVIDENCE OF THAT, WOULDN'T THERE
BE?
>> I MEAN TO DECLASSIFY A
DOCUMENT YOU HAVE TO TELL THE
AGENCY THAT WAS THE ORIGINATOR
OF THE DOCUMENT IT'S
DECLASSIFIED.
YOU CAN'T DECLASSIFY YOUR COPY
AND SAY EVERY OTHER COPY IN THE
GUMP'S POSSESSION ON EVERY
COMPUTER AND EVERY FILE IS
SOMEHOW CLASSIFIED AND YOURS
ISN'T.
SO THERE WAS NO SUCH PROCESS
FOLLOWED HERE.
>> AND IT'S VERY INTERESTING,
JOHN, BECAUSE JUDGE DEARIE, HE'S
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS AREA OF
THE LAW, BUT HOW DOES HE
POTENTIALLY HANDLE THESE HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> SO THE SIMPLEST THING FOR
JUDGE DEARIE TO DO AND AS PREET
SAID HE'S A VERY EXPERIENCED
JUDGE, WORKED ON THE PHISA
COURT.
THE SIMPLEST THING IS SAY IS
THIS CLASSIFIED STILL AND TO THE
EXTENT IT'S MARKED TOP SECRET,
SCI, TK AND ALL THE CAVEATS THAT
GO WITH THAT.
IS IT POSSIBLE FROM THE
INTERVENING TIME FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP LEAVING OFFICE THAT ONE OF
THESE BECAME DECLASSIFIED?
IT IS POSSIBLE BUT HIGHLY
DOUBTFUL, BUT WHY NOT GET THE
CERTIFICATION FROM THE
ORIGINATORS OF THE DOCUMENT,
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT AS THE
SPECIAL MASTER JUDGE DEARIE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
DOCUMENTS AND NEITHER WOULD
TRUMP'S TEAM.
NOW SOMETHING WE'RE STEPPING
OVER HERE AND I'LL DEFER TO ELLE
AND PREET ON THIS IS THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT IN 1978
WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN 1981 WHICH
STEPS RIGHT PAST THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS TO ALL THE REST WHICH
SAYS PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS AFTER
THAT TIME ARE THE PROPERTY OF
THE PUBLIC AND MANAGED BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND NOT THE
PRESIDENT OR FORMER PRESIDENT IN
THIS CASE, WHICH WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT VIOLATION OF LAW.
SO THE SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING
TO HAVE HIS WORK CUT OUT FOR
HIM.
>> PREET, LET ME START WITH YOU.
GO AHEAD.
>> I THINK JOHN IS RIGHT.
WHAT'S IMPLICIT IN WHAT JOHN IS
SAYING IS THE ISSUE WHETHER OR
NOT THESE DOCUMENTSRY MAIN
CLASSIFY AT THE SAME LEVEL AS
THE MARKINGS SUGGEST OR ONE OR
TWO WERE DECLASSIFIED IS NOT THE
CENTRAL STORY HERE.
THIS IS SOMETHING SORT OF
INTERESTING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT'S THE LITIGATION WE'RE SEEING
ABOVE THE SURFACE.
AND IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE THE
JUDGE SAY THERE'S GAMESMANSHIP
GOING ON, BUT THE ISSUE WHETHER
THINGS ARE CLASSIFIED OR NOT
DOES NOT GET TO THE FUNDMENTAL
ISSUE WHETHER THERE'S CRIMINAL
EXPOSURE BECAUSE OF THE STATUTES
BEING INVESTIGATED.
>> WOLF, THIS REALLY GETS TO THE
HEART OF WHY DOJ IS APPEALING.
THEY'RE ESSENTIALLY GOING TO
APPELLATE COURTS AND ARGUING THE
ISSUE OF CLASSIFICATION IS NOT
FOR JUDGES, IS NOT FOR SPECIAL
MASTERS.
IT'S ONLY FOR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, AND THEY'RE DOING THAT
AT THE COST OF DELAY.
IT'S GOING TO GET THROUGH THESE
APPEALS, PROBABLY LONGER THAN
THE ESPECIALLY MASTER HIMSELF.
>> JESSICA, CLEARLY I THINK IT'S
OBVIOUS THE SPECIAL MASTER AS
HE'S CALLED IS TRYING TO KEEP
THIS REVIEW MOVING AT A FAST
PACE, BUT IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DECIDES TO TAKE THEIR
APPEAL ALL THE WAY TO THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT WHAT WOULD THAT DO
TO THE TIME LINE OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION?
>> RIGHT NOW THESE ARE OPERATING
ON SEPARATE TRACKS, THE APPEAL
ON ONE, THE SPECIAL MASTER IS
MOVING FORWARD AS YOU SAID.
HE HAS UNTIL NOVEMBER 30th TO
COMPLETE THE REVIEW OF THESE
11,000 DOCUMENTS.
SO FAR THE DISTRICT COURT, SO
FAR THE APPEALS COURT HASN'T
TAKEN ANY ACTION TO STOP THAT
REVIEW, SO IT IS ONGOING AND
MOVING FORWARD.
IF A COURT DECIDES TO STEP IN,
SURE IT WILL SHORT CIRCU